- Hi.
- Hi, Lisa! Wer ist denn das?
- Das ist Nico.
- Hallo, ich bin Nico.
- Hallo, Nico. Ich bin Sebastian.
Was machst du hier?
- Ich habe ein Problem:
Meine Tasche ist weg und mein Handy
und mein Pass sind auch weg.
Und Yaras Adresse ist auch weg.
- Okay, das ist nicht so gut.
Und woher kommst du?
- Ich komme aus Spanien.
Ich wohne in Sevilla.
- Schön. Und wer ist Yara?
- Yara ist Nicos Tante.
Er hat gesagt, sie hat hier
einen Fahrradladen.
Aber er hat die Adresse nicht.
- Auch nicht so gut. Und wie alt bist du?
- Ich bin 22 Jahre alt. Und du?
Kommst du aus Deutschland?
- Ich bin 25 Jahre.
Und ja, ich komme aus Deutschland.
- Und ich heiße Nina.
Ich komme auch aus Deutschland
und bin 23 Jahre alt. Hi!
- Kann Nico zwei Tage hier wohnen?
- Klar.
- Kein Problem!
- Willkommen in der Wagnergasse!
- Dankeschön!
- Herzlich willkommen!
- Und es gibt eine Party?
- Ja, aber wir haben
ein kleines Problem.
- Die Lampe ist kaputt.
- Kann ich?
- Klar. Hat am Flughafen alles geklappt?
Geht es Emma gut?
- Ja. Emmas Mutter sitzt im Flugzeug und
Emma geht es gut, die ist bei Lotte.
- Ey, wow! Die Lampe funktioniert wieder.
- Super, Nico! Danke!
Möchtest du etwas trinken?
- Trinken?
- Ja, trinken, ein Getränk!
- Oder zwei.
- Oder drei.